[Musica]
buongiorno
credo che ci sia un aspetto che forse
condividerete con me e cioè la
percezione di insicurezza che ci pervade
ormai da qualche anno la sicurezza e
l'insicurezza economica insicurezza
dovuta alla criminalità
però questo confligge poi con i dati che
in realtà riguardano la criminalità
perché sennò andiamo a vedere in questo
spaccato abbastanza ampio dal 2004 fino
al 2016 ci renderemo conto che gli
omicidi e tentati omicidi sono diminuiti
terribilmente e se facciamo lo stesso
confronto con gli altri paesi d'europa
vedete l'italia in quel rettangolino
possiamo dire che l'italia è un'oasi
felice
questo grazie soprattutto alla autorità
giudiziaria grazie alle forze di polizia
che ogni giorno sacrificano anche la
loro vita per darci la sicurezza però
c'è qualcosa che nel frattempo è
accaduto ed è accaduto a partire dagli
anni ottanta io è lì che inizia la mia
attività come biologo forense qui vedete
un caso che ha segnato la storia
criminale è anche la storia italiana
cioè il sequestro e l'omicidio
dell'onorevole moro ma quello per il
quale voglio attrarre la vostra
attenzione e vedete questa
frequentazione del luogo soprattutto a
carico e intorno alla renault in cui
ricorderete fu trovato morto
l'onorevole moro che in realtà per noi
rappresentava allora come oggi la scena
del crimine
però nessuno era cosciente che quella
scena andava tutelata che andava
protetta e allora proprio da quegli anni
si è sviluppata progressivamente la
prova scientifica c'è una prova
scientifica entrata nella attività
investigativa e io ho avuto il
privilegio di vivere
proprio questa progressione ma se
riavvolgiamo un po il film dobbiamo
anche ricordarci ce lo ricorda svetonio
nelle vite di cesare che il primo la
prima testimonianza di dell'uso della
prova scientifica e nell'autopsia di
giulio cesare e l'afa antistanti schio e
il medico curante di giulio cesare ma si
trova costretto a determinare quali sono
state le cause della morte quale colpo
da arma da taglio ha causato la sua
morte per arrivare poi al primo caso in
caso di violenza sessuale seguito dall
omicidio di due giovani ragazze in
inghilterra in cui per la prima volta
siamo negli anni 84 86 viene utilizzata
la prova del dna al dna fa ingresso in
questo panorama e si presenta come una
possibilità che diventerà irrinunciabile
straordinariamente forte per assicurare
alla giustizia i delinquenti ma tutto
quello che noi facciamo nei nostri
laboratori così come nella scena del
crimine lo dobbiamo a quest'uomo un
antesignano da questo punto di vista e
damon lo card che nel 1910 con un
principio il principio di interscambio
di lo card che si condensa in una frase
piena di fascino e di attualità
ogni contatto lascia una traccia se ci
pensate qualsiasi frequentazione noi
facciamo personale o di ambienti in
quelle frequentazioni
noi lasciamo delle tracce e estraiamo
altre tracce che diventano i testimoni
dei nostri contatti del nostro percorso
beh questo ha fatto sì che tutte quelle
scelte che tutte quelle scienze che fino
allora non avevano avuto uno sviluppo
accanto all'attività investigativa
diventano le scienze forensi e cioè la
biologia la chimica la fisica
l'ingegneria concentrate proprio nella
necessità di poter dare delle risposte a
che cosa ha dei reperti a delle tracce
che sono sulla vittima che sono sulla
scena del crimine
questo è un elenco sicuramente parziale
ma oggi proprio in virtù della grande
potenza delle scienze
noi possiamo dare un senso e un
significato agli insetti ai pollini alle
vernici alle fibre non vi cito
naturalmente le tracce più convenzionali
come quelle biologiche tutto può essere
importante per legarci a quell'evento e
indicarci le responsabilità ma
naturalmente non soltanto tracce fisiche
perché oggi a quelle si sono sommate le
tracce psicologiche quelle che vanno a
studiare la vittima che ne traggono
elementi per capire quale può essere
stato il movente è ancora una volta
comprendere quale può essere quella rosa
di sospettati per quel determinato reato
e poi naturalmente le tracce
informatiche tutto quello che noi
lasciamo attraverso i nostri dispositivi
il telefono e lasciamo non solo le
tracce delle nostre comunicazioni ma
anche della nostra posizione e devo dire
che se il dna nel 1984 rivoluzionato il
modo di fare le indagini informatica
forense ha sicuramente solo superato
queste possibilità che la genetica aveva
ma è tutto così semplice e no sarebbe
assolutamente noioso non saremo lì
costantemente immersi nella ricerca
perché molte tracce sono invisibili e un
modo per cercare le tracce invisibili
sia quelle biologici a quelle non
biologiche e l'uso ad esempio delle
lampade forensi che sfruttano lo spettro
completo della luce che sapete è
costituito da frequenze d'onda che vanno
dall'ultravioletto all'infrarosso e ci
consentono come in questo caso questa è
una maglia vestita da un omicida di far
chiarezza su delle tracce che non vedete
all'interno di questa maglia ma che è
illuminata all'infrarosso ci dà la
possibilità di individuare tracce che
hanno una genesi differente ci sono
tracce da contatto ci sono tracce da
proiezione che riscontrate poi con le
dichiarazioni di questo indagato allora
imputato e condannato dopo hanno fatto
sì di poter capire che tutto quello che
raccontava
assolutamente mendace e poi c'è la
chimica la chimica come il luminol molto
molto famoso in fondo nelle indagini
anche in quelle che vengono proposte dai
media ma è una reazione che insieme e
accanto alla presenza di emoglobina
anche in quantità estremamente ridotte
permette di vedere effettivamente se ci
sono ancora delle tracce
quelle due fotografie che vedete da
basso sono vere e si riferiscono
forse lo ricorderete al duplice omicidio
di novi ligure in cui prima a sinistra
vedete una cucina che è caratterizzata
soltanto da tanta sporcizia a parte quei
segni fatti col gesso e a destra invece
vedete le orme di piedi insanguinati che
hanno scandito i movimenti e quindi il
comportamento di omar favaro che era uno
dei due assassini di quella famigliola
poi ci sono strumenti di misura come il
laser 3d che ci permettono non solo di
misurare ma di modellare quindi di fare
ipotesi che riguardano appunto quella
che è stata la dinamica e poi vedete no
due mondi completamente differenti
quello di giulia così creativo quello un
po cruento che riguarda invece il mio
lavoro ma anche io mi occupo di macchie
di macchie di sangue perché noi andiamo
ad osservare la forma le dimensioni e la
distribuzione delle macchie di sangue
perché una macchia quando si muove
nell'atmosfera come vedete in questa
veloce animazione è una palletta ci
hanno interviene più tecnico e uno
steroide che si accorcia e si allunga
soltanto perché risente della forza di
gravità
ma le macchie di sangue non solo sono
soggette alla forza di gravità perché
per che compiranno una traiettoria
saranno proiettate da una forza e allora
da questo punto di vista vediamo
un'altra animazione e vedete come con un
solo evento noi otteniamo una
popolazione di tracce ematiche
naturalmente quando interveniamo poi su
quella scena è chiaro che la gamba non
c'è il piede non c'è ma noi sappiamo ex
post ricostruire in funzione di quelle
morfologie e di quelle traiettorie
qual è stato l'area di origine c'è da
quale punto quelle tracce si sono
generate e questo accanto alla
possibilità di capire sono tracce
solamente che sono soggiogati dalla
forza di gravità quindi gocciolamento o
contatto o sono tracce da proiezione ma
pensate anche le aree non caratterizzate
dalle tracce cioè le aree di vuoto ci
danno dalle informazioni su che cosa su
quella che è la posizione reciproca
aggressore vittima che poi ricostruiamo
grazie alla disponibilità di software
che oggi hanno facilitato moltissimo le
nostre attività io quando ho iniziato
negli stati uniti occuparmi di questo
non vi dico era ancora forse più
affascinante di adesso ma misuravo
macchia per macchia tiravo le stringhe
cioè dei fili più o meno rigidi mi
calcolavo le traiettorie e con lo studio
delle singole traiettorie arrivavo a
determinare quello che voi vedete qui
l'aria d'origine senza strumenti
informatici meno male però che ci sono
errori voglio raccontare un caso è un
caso vero è un omicidio che però parte
come un suicidio e il suicidio di
valentina salamone la vedete ii e quella
ragazza sospesa da quella fune nella
foto a sinistra
tutti pensano che valentina si sia
suicidata perché in crisi col suo
ragazzo è in crisi con la vita e con la
sua famiglia e per molti giorni questo
caso viene affrontato come un suicidio
ma c'è un padre e la mia storia
professionale mi fa incontrare molti
padri che vogliono giustizia che si
impone che non ci crede che vuole
veramente capire che cosa è successo
allora
riuscirà a far sì che la procura
generale a pochi
la l'indagine e quindi abbandoni quello
che era stato fatto fino a quel momento
per cercare di fare degli
approfondimenti questi approfondimenti
li vedete
sintetizzati in quel sandro alessandro
che indossava valentina quando è stata
uccisa prima è sospesa dopo e vedete
sulla destra cerchiato di rosso
una macchia di sangue un accumulo beh se
notate i piedi di valentina anno il
tallone più alto rispetto alle dita ma
questa macchia che voi vedete a destra
sulla sul sandalo e nella posizione
nettamente contraria significa che è
valentina è stata ferita prima ed è
stata mantenuta in una posizione
assolutamente diversa dalla sospensione
quando era già ferita ed è stata poi
sospesa in limine vite cioè quando stava
morendo perché morirà per asfissia ma a
seguito delle lesioni che qualcuno gli
ha provocato e allora questo aspetto
questo particolare così importante farà
sì che ci si possa approfondire ancora
di più fare una sperimentazione si
chiama esperimento giudiziale cioè
quello di utilizzare una persona della
stessa corporatura di valentina per
dimostrare che non poteva fare tutto da
sola che non sarebbe riuscita né a
passare la corda su quella tra ve ne
tanto meno a fare formare quel nodo e
allora poi tutto questo avrà un
ulteriore approfondimento perché quei
sandali ci diranno poi chi in ipotesi è
stato dico così perché siamo ancora
nella fase del processo di primo grado e
quindi giusto presumere l'innocenza fino
a quando non si celebri il terzo grado
di giudizio ma il chi era il suo ragazzo
che lascerà delle tracce all'interno di
questo sandalo miscelate naturalmente
con il sangue di valentina un caso che
sarebbe finito come un suicidio ma che
appunto celava un omicidio grazie
proprio a questo studio vedete la
sintesi il binomio dna e b piano lo
studio delle tracce di sangue
beh devo dire che da biologo non avrei
mai pensato a questo evoluzione
del dna ma sono 30 anni che lo
utilizziamo e io ho avuto il privilegio
di privilegio posso parlare accanto alla
tristezza di occuparmi di un caso
altrettanto tragico e cioè la strage di
capaci
qualche giorno fa appunto abbiamo
ricordato quell'evento e mi occupai
insieme a tutto spinella dell'analisi di
quelle cicche di sigaretta che poi ci
consentivano di risalire al comando
insieme a naturalmente alle indagini
tradizionali e poi avete visto quanto il
dna e grazie soltanto forse al dna siamo
arrivati a capire chi fosse
l'omicida di yara gambirasio con uno
screening genetico che per la prima
volta così ampio cioè l'analisi dvd più
di 20.000 dna per arrivare a capire
quale fosse la paternità di chi fosse la
paternità di quella traccia di sangue ma
il dna non è soltanto questo è banca
dati e per fortuna anche noi abbiamo una
banca dati ormai ma è dna non soltanto
umano perché dna vegetale dna animale
c'è un caso che per il quale già i media
hanno parlato che sicuramente per il
quale conoscerete presto dei particolari
che è quello di un altro polk ace cioè
l'omicidio di serena mollicone che è
stato risolto comunque ha dato elementi
importanti grazie al dna che lo legava a
dei frammenti vegetali di una porta
quindi pensate no quanto effettivamente
la potenza di questo dna che
naturalmente oggi ci dà la
consapevolezza di poter risolvere
tantissimi casi non risolti allora
quelli che si chiamano col keys o casi a
pista fredda come l'omicidio
dell'olgiata che è stato risolto 17 anni
dopo che era stato commesso anche qui
con degli errori investigativi
incredibili ma non solo questo perché il
dna e affascinante quanto potente
non ha limiti perché le nuove
possibilità che ci offre quello di
individuare il colore degli occhi il
colore dei capelli il peso la forma del
volto cioè elementi investigativi che
sono preziosi soprattutto nella fase
iniziale delle indagini e non solo dna
non solo dna per questo la ricerca è
estremamente affascinante pensate alla
popolazione di microorganismi che ognuno
di noi si porta addosso e che è
diventato un altro strumento di
identificazione o di individuazione
dell'intervallo di morte e che dire
degli odori cioè tutte quelle sostanze
anche quelle variabili in ognuno di noi
per le nostre abitudini per la nostra
professione per il nostro modo di vivere
che stanno diventando un altro presidio
per l'identificazione
tutto questo però ha sempre poi una
finalizzazione e non posso in
conclusione non citare questa iniziativa
statunitense che si chiama nello saints
project che anche in italia ha avuto i
natali qualche tempo fa un'iniziativa
che è partita proprio dalla
consapevolezza che il dna poteva
risolvere tanti casi irrisolti e
guardate in dal 1989 365 persone
riconosciute innocenti ma la cosa
strabiliante che 20 di queste erano
stati condannati a morte ed erano degli
innocenti sono stati salvati dal dna
dalla scienza e in più del 50 per cento
questi soggetti hanno consentito poi la
loro sono il loro sogno era consentito
attraverso il nuovo analisi del dna di
individuare i veri autori allora quali
risvegli beh io direi il risveglio
dell'impegno sociale
il risveglio del senso di responsabilità
della passione della ricerca costante
della dedizione verso i nostri cittadini
perché come ci ha detto einstein il
mondo è un bel posto e per esso vale la
pena di lottare
[Applauso]